foreign
[Music]
do not attempt the training techniques
you're about to see without consulting a
professional previously on
crowder911 i don't think joe biden knows
what he's doing a physically
inappropriate politician he's at the
point where he gropes every person that
walks by
this joe biden was clearly out of
control
[Music]
that's not good
[Music]
since crowder last helped train former
vice president joe biden he's fallen
back into some bad habits
yeah the methods worked at first but
former vice president joe biden
definitely regressed
he's sniffing people a whole lot less
but he's gotten more handsy and recently
he's been pooping on all the carpets
it sucks to clean up it really does and
when you walk with no shoes and you get
it between your toes it's the worst
thing
when we last left quarter black and his
former vice president joe biden i taught
them how to set boundaries in a calm
assertive state and keep it from
escalating but it seems they haven't
kept the rules of no talk no touch no
eye contact and so former vice president
biden regress into an aggressive state
how'd you do thanks for coming in yeah
doing good well we've been working with
former vice president here and uh he's
been sniffing people a lot less which is
good that's good but since we made the
decision to bring him inside he's been
just pooping on all of our carpets wow
we don't know what to do okay
that's the problem he's making for the
hey hey hey hey
hey like that yes just like that on the
carpet
he's not even doing the on the wood
no he it seems deliberate that's right
oh man i needed to sit down with corner
black to get to the root cause of this
negative behavior okay so quarter black
how long has it been happening like that
uh several months now actually it's it's
been a year okay it's getting pretty bad
so that's a pr and that's the main
problem is the poop on the carpet yeah
we have small children around so that's
a that's a concern yes get serious
now how old is former vice president joe
biden now
he's 92.
okay now sometimes with older former
vice presidents it's important to
remember that pooping on the carpet is
not always their fault he's not have a
awareness of time or space when he's
escalated he could be on the carpet or
he could be
on mars
right now he's saying
that's my car this is my carpet
i can poop on your carpet
that's make your carpet my carpet so
what you're saying is all these issues
he's been having is
it's because of me it's my fault
that's right
does not feel good
no
the good news is i can help to fix snap
the brain out of
i hope so
[Music]
i'm excited i'm excited if we can get it
fixed
if not i'm gonna put them down though
that's right
okay
[Music]
joe hey joe you did a good job out there
[Music]
now after some training i felt like
quarter black was going to be able to
get calm assertive control over the
pooping on the carpet but that's when i
saw a whole bigger problem of fish in
the bucket to cook coming up on crowder
9-1-1 guys let's go to the shower joe
with garrett's daughter she's nice
hey joe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i usually don't do the slurp on the
evening streams but have a little bit of
cerveza here so uh good to be with you
hey guys look really quickly we're about
to the uh
former vice president joe biden uh fact
check state of the union
i assume he'll be late
so live in real time we'll be fact
checking everything uh you can use
obviously the the hashtag i think it's
s-o-t-o-s-o-t-u state of the union is
the abbreviated version on twitter right
on tick-tock where we still have not
been banned not yet so far despite
accusing xi jinping of having a micro
wiener
i don't know what it takes let's keep
just up in the annie we're going to keep
up in the annie uh so we'll be live and
of course you can also use the promo
code we ask that you use uh biden fact
check and that is a promo code as well
where you get twenty dollars off boom
join up tonight 20 dollars off mug club
livestream.com club and we'll be doing
another half hour at least tonight
wrapping up the evening's festivities so
uh we have dave land out here with me
how are you sir ahoy i'm good how about
you uh you know as good as i can be
knowing that this is the state of
affairs in our country and globally
and uh in this studio
i'm excited you guys to use the bathroom
before the stream well
i don't know sure well the stream okay
all right
by the way you don't have to walk in
when i'm using the restroom to cross
street it's a joke once i well i think
it's a joke every day well twice yeah it
just gets to be grading and i don't know
he's a tremendous lockpicker and gerald
how are you gerald i'm well how are you
steven i'm doing all right right now
they're talking about uh on cnn so we'll
bring this up here you guys so we can
have it so we will have the stream on so
this is the only stream you need to
watch i know before we had to be careful
so i don't have a cough button because
of copyright tonight we are going to try
and just punch in and punch out so you
can hear most of the state of the union
address and with these long applause
breaks where everyone of course will be
getting standing o's really yes long
applause breaks because he needs it no
it's going to be him long breathing
breaks yes long breathing breaks and
they will stand up and applaud ring
it'll be like tom hanks on punchline
he'll be sitting there talking
someone help me pretty much so you are
supposed to applaud here it says hold
for applause right i'm just excited to
see him come out i don't know if kamala
has hidden the tennis balls from his
walker right
bus your place replace them with golf
balls there's a very good chance that
she's already buttered the staircase
what why is there a banana and a podium
what's going on what's going on here
president
if you do take a shot every time he
calls her the president you will be dead
in one yes you will be dead which
reminds us we have a drinking game
tonight where you can watch along with
us uh and drink can you uh bring them up
there uh
and uh token allen explain to people
every time you hear this ding
do you have the there it is there we go
all right keegan let's be faster to the
draw on that i'm not the ding oh okay
i'm the ding man i just it's two zippers
yeah i'm gonna say more of a dingbat
right correct
that's what
that's good all right so token one what
are the rules there's sizzling all right
so number one if biden has a moment so
he gaps he stutters he forgets something
oh lord okay so alcohol poisoning need
number two everyone's gonna die
yeah he blames russia for anything i hit
a ding every time he gives you the
number there tim the tool man all right
number three
number three he promotes infrastructure
or green energy commonly known as
imaginary energy yes
number four he encourages the vaccine
okay or number five he mentions racism
or white supremacy man well if we have
to drink like this for the entire uh
stream i'll be feeling like i got my
fourth booster
yes well you might hit your head and die
right uh no no no no no what happened no
that doesn't happen no i'm not saying
nobody has any babies talking about in
the drinking yeah from drinking nobody's
drinking that's why we also want to warn
you oh you were implying he was implying
you're speaking you were speaking ill of
the science no no no no no no no never
we would never there's science is not a
theory it's a fact yes fact it's
mutually agreed and by science we mean
what fouchy says depending on the day
well yeah we take a poll we go
really quickly did you guys see this
that dr oz was debate was wanted to
debate fauci dr oz's running as a
republican and it was trending all over
twitter with people saying oh oz yeah
maybe uh the my pillow guy is more your
speech like he's an active surgeon a
world-class surgeon
dr fauci hasn't seen a patient in 40
years oh wow i would take that he's also
answered every question anyone's ever
asked him about health care right that's
his job as a matter of fact if you
google right now dr oz real doctor you
will find all articles before he ran for
office saying actually dr oz is a
totally legitimate doctor who's really
good at what he does okay so our
predictions for tonight gerald you first
um and this is not like a bold
prediction on this first part but i
think he's going to try and find a way
to blame the issue in ukraine on donald
trump's policies i know there's a lot of
people taking a risk no no i know that's
not a risk uh taking a flyer there
gerald i'm just saying that yeah i don't
know he's
he's definitely gonna try to tie that
because for some reason they can't get
off of trump right yeah it's gonna be
that's definitely gonna be it we will
have some fact checks for that we're
ready for that one because we see it
coming but then i think he is also gonna
try and distract people from the economy
that is if he if that is the third rail
for them right now going into midterms
and he's going to do everything that he
can to blame the economy no third rail
of black lives matter recidivists pushed
an asian in front of that's true but
he's going to blame the account on the
russia invasion even though that just
happened yes and the economy has sucked
for a while that's a good point okay i
think that i think uh you'll also see
him try and imply that uh donald trump
weakened nato and this is going to be a
big thing you've seen this narrative
going out well first off let me hear
dave what do you think i think uh four
mini strokes a grand mal seizure
and a partridge in a pear tree yes how
long do you think it will take him to
realize he has cracked his pants don't
be a jerkbait well he's already gonna
walk out with it in his pants a little
squishy so you're saying well i think
tonight's show is sponsored by imodium
by the way go out and get you
some uh i really do think he's gonna
blame most of it on trump he's probably
not gonna mention he's probably gonna go
hey don't look at your phones at the dow
today because oh my goodness right i
looked i took one look at my fidelity
investment account and i thought well
there goes half of everything
um so yeah i just heard we lost imodium
but we do have pepto-bismol for upset
stomach nausea former vice presidency
and diarrhea oh yeah uncomfortable
excellent i'm excited larry i think
it's gonna just ski in with us
get her down no i think he's gonna uh
blame the economy on trump because
clearly that was his fault
are they getting ready to come in there
no no they say four minutes there's
several other people yeah they have to
announce a bunch of people no one cares
about who's the guy with the scarf why
this why are the blue scarfs that's a
lady with a scarf oh it's because they
want to stand with ukraine oh okay that
makes sense that's what it is for the
first time good for them oh that's great
and stephen king are taking a stand
there's a supreme court yeah i think the
real rapist
blames everyone but himself
what would have been great is if
kavanaugh walked in with a beer helmet
oh yeah and just looked over at cory
booker i came here he's looking at you
kid just kidding keep acting like you're
straight inviting everyone to a pool
party i like beer he will be talking
about uh the supreme court nominee
probably trying to tout that victory
absolutely you know very little
qualifications uh brown jackson i never
know how to pronounce the first name um
so i do think this look i think he's
going to try and they've been trying to
consistently blame donald trump for
russia and here's we can get into the
minutia and sometimes people will say
that i'm i'm being reductive by the way
uh of course dave is a former alcoholic
cannot drink he'll be doing without no
the drinking game not doing that either
yeah he'll be doing a drug yes
by the end of it he has brain damage and
aids liberace's son will be here and
dave will be doing nitric
painted gold for some reason by the end
dave just bellied down on a piano yeah
scandal yeah i can play chopsticks on a
typewriter look at me go
oh i'm getting weaker um so i do think
you know they're really trying to blame
donald trump for russia now before i get
into the minutia here let me ask you
this and you guys can comment obviously
we're not right now while we're live and
we'll be taking your chats on mugla but
many of you will be watching this
probably tomorrow uh or well if you're
watching it tomorrow today
um
so
uh oh there's
i'm sorry miss biden who
your husband's dumb
i bet you think you're a doctor i never
thought he'd [ __ ] his pants he laughed i
think no i didn't that would be a lie
she's a doctor what like is that she
tells everybody she's a doctor she's a
doctor of not love that's what it is
yeah she's a doctor of frigid that's
what i thought okay
and uh
trickman's lay's clothes stare they call
me
they call me doctor no love
i will say they want to avoid of course
the approval ratings now they've been
trying to blame donald trump for russia
before i get into the details does
anyone here and we've talked about the
real problem with russia right and two
things can be true your heart can break
for the people of the ukraine and you
can also understand that it's not
america's job to go out and police the
world and to send americans to die for
this conflict in russia both things can
be true i think these are reasonable
positions to hold you held one position
lane holds another position uh because
where does it stop with russia i do
think i lean towards the fact that
they're not really capable of becoming
uh the superpower they want to it's a
flex however the concern of course is
russia um outlying itself with china we
did a segment on this you can go to
thursdays or was it monday show was it
last week this week monday this way yeah
that's right it was monday's show um let
me ask you genuinely you can comment
does anyone out there i know many of you
watching a lot of you are not
necessarily conservatives you might be
more liberal
does anyone actually believe that we're
in a stronger position with china right
now than with donald trump does anybody
actually believe that donald trump was
anything short of the only president in
modern american history to be tough on
china here's the thing
this guy can't talk about the uh the
alliance with china this party can't
talk about china they can't talk tough
with china why because they've been uh
aligning themselves with china for a
long time think about this when mitt
romney talked about the threat of russia
uh back in those debates in uh i believe
it was was it 2008 was it 2000 it was
when he got re-elected 2012 12. 2012. uh
barack obama said uh now the 80s called
they want their foreign policy back and
then when donald trump talked about
china i believe even had this former
vice president certainly there's pete
butt gig i don't know oh i guess i
thought he was going to come out with a
breast pump
i thought
looks like he just got off a horse yes
walking bow legged are we pete yes
um
here's your seatless bike they went
after donald trump saying well you can't
speak this way about china one of our
most valuable partners you know in a
global economy because they want to push
this idea of a global economy and who do
they want to align themselves with the
democratic party
china so they really are kneecapped they
cannot address the actual threat that
most americans are concerned with not
only china of course with taiwan which
is more international a lot of americans
aren't following that i believe that
it's scorched earth if china moves at
all on taiwan and they've been
insinuating that they would but uh we
need to worry about the alliance with
russia and with china that's something
that they cannot address so they have to
start dancing circles around this that's
why they're going to have to go to green
energy that's why they're going to have
to talk about covet by the way more kova
deaths under former vice president joe
biden than donald trump
while we're talking about nato donald
trump was the first president to
actually strengthen nato what they meant
when they try to say that donald trump
weakened nato is donald trump was tough
with nato where of course nato for those
of you who don't know once nato was
basically created these uh countries
that signed onto nato were supposed to
spend two percent of their gdp on
military personnel
military spending uh toward nato right
that was the agreement we paid the
united states i believe was three point
four percent the average from other
countries was well under two i believe
it might have been 1.5 there were many
countries that paid less than one
percent so donald trump said you better
you better start paying your fair share
or oops maybe uh putin's going to march
through here and uh hear the limitations
of your wibbid
see you driven before them oh that
sounds that sounds terrible terrible i
would hate for that to happen that's
what other people say would happen i
would never say that so
and for the first time there was an
increase in spending the country started
finally paying their fair share nato
spending went up under donald trump what
the left means when they say we need to
strengthen nato is the united states
needs to foot the bill and this is my
question and again you guys can probably
respond if you're watching this live on
twitter we'll read some of those tweets
and we'll read your chats with the uh
the hashtag bidenfactcheck that's also
the promo code 20 off
is um if people went years decades not
spending their two percent
with nato okay because that's the
agreement right all of us are aligned to
protect each other
is it morally right for them to benefit
from the united states military to
defend them and when you have places you
have countries for example use germany
as an example where they've said the oh
the internet is a human right we're able
to provide all of these rights and
people saying socialized socialize
healthcare for our citizens for new
americans blah blah blah
yeah because you don't spend money on
your own defense let alone the
international defense that you promised
you guys get to service your country
with free [ __ ] at the expense of us
protecting the free world that's the
important component with nato because
guess what if other people aren't doing
it and i think they should have to pay
back all the money they didn't pay or
guess what you're out or at the very
least you don't get any defense from
nato or any other allied country
certainly certainly the united states
until you pay your amount that's a fair
agreement right i think so yeah i think
honestly you're just saying we want to
strengthen these countries so that they
can defend themselves how many times
does another country or as kamala harris
put it a large country have to march
through a small country that's next door
before you guys realize hey we probably
ought to spend some money on defense so
we don't get our butts kicked right
right that's all donald trump was trying
to do and they're trying to spin that on
him and i think it's better to occupy a
country for two decades and then just
leave all our stuff there yeah well
pallets of cash that we could not yes or
do you like leave blackhawk helicopters
like uh like a dollar's worth of i was
pissed off about the workout equipment
honestly that was left yeah exactly
although i don't i don't know how how
many uh isis members will really take
advantage of that total gym oh look it's
a good quarterback
oh yes a peloton it's what they've
always wanted
it was just the bikes that lindsay lohan
used on the commercials and we wanted to
get them out of america's wagons you're
on your peloton of course you see a
little icon for one abdul
daddy who's a khalid sheik muhammad his
times are fantastic yeah let's see on
epo
i
i think we're both saying is pretty
spot on i mean they're going to push
division about the wrong things they're
going to push fear about the wrong
things instead of having you focus on
what we should really be worried about
because that's what they've spent the
last two years doing that's what they
spent the last year of trump's
presidency doing it's what they spent
the last year doing and i
when was the last time we were this bad
well the united states yeah uh about
four years ago
yeah roughly roughly right maybe five i
don't know if
roughly i'm just ballparking it yeah i
mean even a little like longer than that
yeah
i would i mean this bad yeah by the way
he's four minutes late so i just wonder
if he's still there like knocking on the
stall right now mr trump looks like the
muppet sorry mr bye
mr biden they're looking it's like the
muppet show where it has his name that
they put his star on the toilet i think
what you mean is on time yes yeah yes
exactly uh really quickly though he
prepared for tonight and he actually
brought in the big guns we do actually
have footage i believe is this correct
token now we have footage of uh former
vice president joe biden almost one
second we almost have it yeah we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna keep it up
here in just a second here look at this
these people are acting like it's a wine
mixer yeah they are it really isn't me
and they're all looking at uh what's the
guy kavanaugh like nothing happened
right
cavanaugh's standing back he's just
standing there like by himself like we
all know oh yeah yeah remember that
whole rape thing it wasn't real yeah it
wasn't real we're sorry about that we
just tried to destroy your life and
reputation for all time but you know
what let bygones be bygones it's almost
like when people after a fight you know
whether it's like
lennox oh wait is this him yet no not
him who is that lady that looks like the
witch from robin hood i know that looks
like a bite in back there though
is that could be
who this is
here we go all right now let's hear who
it is
of the united states
all right
all right keegan you can probably
feather it is that the secret service
lady right there
is that that is body man uh is that his
bodyguard he's like yeah i want equity
in bodyguards what does that mean i want
the lady from the hover round commercial
with osteoporosis follow the lady that
smells like a grandmother she will lead
you to the museum you really just need
someone stronger yeah
i bet you if you grabbed former vice
president biden's wrist and just tweaked
it the wrong way hey look hey swalwell
the guy who was banging a chinese spy
how is that man still allowed to be a
representative in government is that not
like close to treason i mean like
shaking an old broom from the 50s
just dust like where you know what maybe
let's say he goes his left hand is a
dust pan what is this oh this is a weird
i'm the i'm the six dollar man
go have a good speech am i the president
oh lord oh did you see that pat that pat
was like
you're doing okay big guy yeah that
wasn't a confident pet no nobody's
nobody pat's him hard except there's
going to be
the size of a melon
he's getting he's going to have a blood
clot yes there's a fight
no former vice president has never been
in a fight oh he always claims he likes
to take people out behind the bike rack
so this is a problem for me right here
he's he's shaking some hands and not
others on the supreme court it's like he
walked right past kavanaugh and amy
coney barrett and he's like i'll go i'll
go shake these guys hands that's fine
yeah yeah that's just look at how he's
walking
look at how he's walking this is the
representative of the free world for
crying out loud and i know it shouldn't
matter i don't know if you can bring up
the hashtag to on the screen so people
can see it's the biden fact check we'll
be fact checking everything live uh here
as much as we can look look he has to
use he has to use the podium to get up
there oh boy i'm surprised i didn't
install a ramp
all right let's hear it by the way
expect a lot of long claps because these
people are all going to is he looking at
his cards they've been trained or he's
handing them out well i think i'm here
i'm here to hand out diplomas yeah she's
going to rip up her copy of the speech
just like she did last time with trump
expect them to clap they're they're just
a yes man like you're doing great kid
do you want a bread basket oh look at
this did you see that that is
significantly closer i don't know if we
can get people to bring it up from the
control room looks like that those
prompters are significantly closer than
they've been in the past could just be
an optical illusion
who is coming in now except that they're
right there yes all right okay hey look
i love that one guy's wearing a mask
he's gonna die on that hill yeah
yeah why are there's three people
wearing masks in the rest of the places
no we're about they just made him wear
it because he's wearing he has bad
breath no it's like
something else maybe let's double mask
it why me why me because you smell like
you've been in a truck stall with george
michael because you look perfectly
healthy
hit your face pick one
whatever it is i just don't want your
face look he's pointing like he's babe
ruth except he's pointing to where he's
gonna bungle it yeah okay all right
everyone inviting that hashtag biden
fact check hashtag thank you so much
sotu
so adam speaker
madam vice president our first lady and
second gentleman
members of congress in the cabinet
justice of the supreme court
my fellow americans
last year covet 19 kept us apart
this year we're finally together again
tonight
yeah why is that tonight we meet
is democrats republicans independence
most importantly dang
the duty to one another
to america
to the american people to the
constitution back there and an
unwavering resolve
that freedom will always triumph over
tyranny another slur
we're sorry folks
we did this to you
clap already that's a standing o
because of freedom triumphing over
turning his wife's like i haven't had a
standing out in years ago
russia's vladimir putin sought to shake
the very foundations of the free world
thinking he could make it bend
to his menacing ways no that's kamala
but he badly miscalculated
he thought he could roll into ukraine
and the world would roll over
instead
he met with a mall a wall of strength he
never anticipated or imagined he met
ukrainian people
i don't think jennifer drink for every
one of her necklines what'd you think he
was going to meet the other people i
don't know he invaded you
the president that's the ukrainian
ambassador i think i thought she was
part of a caravan
i thought she was a gypsy in their
fearlessness their courage
literally inspires the world
groups of citizens
blocking tanks with their bodies
everyone from students to retirees to
teachers turned soldiers defending their
homeland how they do that with guns and
this struggle president zielinski said
in his speech the european parliament
light will win over darkness
ukrainian ambassador to the united
states is here tonight sitting with the
first lady oh was that supposed to be
ambassador
he said ukrainian bastard to the
she's world there
thank god she got out thank you thank
you
look at how jill is standing six feet
away from the ambassador not because of
cove but she just thinks she's gross
she's just a hug
russia hadn't invaded you we never would
have met right
right she's strong she's resolved
i mean brave sure strong i don't know
that she could deadlift 250. stop trying
to sell me turquoise jewelry
i do not need another mood ring
yes
no united states america stand with the
ukrainian people
throughout our history
we've learned this lesson
when dictators
do not pay a price for their aggression
they cause more chaos
they keep moving they do and the costs
the threats to the america
and america to the world oh god it keeps
rising drink
that's why the nato alliance was created
to secure peace and stability in europe
after world war ii
the united states is a member along with
29 other nations
it matters
american diplomacy matters
american resolve matters
putin's latest attack on ukraine was
premeditated
and totally unprovoked
he rejected repeated repeated efforts at
diplomacy
he thought the west and nato wouldn't
respond why is that he thought he could
divide us at home
in this chamber in this nation
he thought he could divide us in europe
as well
but putin was wrong
we are ready we are united and that's
what we did we stayed united we prepared
extensively and carefully we spent
months building coalitions of other
freedom-loving nations in europe and the
americans america to the asia
all right drink continents 311 nations
to confront
you spent months like many of you i
spent countless hours unifying your
european allies yeah an hour 15 before
your afternoon
and precisely how we would try to
falsify
and justify his aggression what
we countered russia's lies with the
truth
and now
now that he's acted the three free world
was holding him accountable geez come on
man
i don't even remember any of the other
drinking rules can you guys bring them
up
as well as countries like the united
kingdom i thought it was a blame rusher
for anything promoted
and supporting the people of ukraine
putin is now isolated from the world
more than he has ever been
no he's not together
he's he actually has more real estate
yes he's together it's true that's like
someone someone widening your backyard
are you feeling isolated yet what i've
got you right where i want you ah i'm
gonna we're also putting a golf course
in back which will be municipal you'll
have access to it ah
we're squeezing the vice putting a
privacy fence up to your deck
sanctions
have you stopped buying the world's
largest banks in the international
financial system preventing russia's
central bank from defending the russia
ruble ruble what the mickey mouse
sorry
drink
defending the russian ruby
we're choking russia's out
make sure you guys intersperse some
water in this drinking game
for years to come that's just ginger
tonight
i say to the russian oligarchs and the
corrupt leaders who built billions of
dollars off this they just show someone
who looks aggravated to be there
the united states
get up again oh my gosh
shouldn't have shouldn't have done leg
day this morning yeah they're looking
around at each other like really we're
we're okay i guess we're standing okay
did you guys hear that
what the hell are we clapping for
rupaul's dedicated task force to go
after the crimes of the russian
oligarchs
we're joining with european allies to
find and seize their yachts their luxury
apartments their private jets
oh come on
ill-begotten gains and tonight i'm
announcing that we will see your it will
be gone closing off american airspace to
all russian flights further isolating
russia and adding additional squeeze
down there
i'm sorry hold on
you mean they can't fly over here yeah
we're not exactly on the way to you
there's one w nba team from russia like
son of a [ __ ]
i was really looking forward to pulling
off weave
i like the woman to the right who's just
like russian stock market has lost 40
percent of
the trading remains suspended
the russian economy is reeling
and putin alone is the one to blame
together with our allies not trump you
mean we're providing support to the
ukrainians in their fight for freedom
military assistance
economic assistance by the way to be
clear donald trump provided in 2017 47
million dollars in arms
uh 210 anti-tank missiles 35 launchers
in 2019 he approved another 39 million
150 javelin missiles and two launchers
he increased the overall spending and
troop deployment in europe so just to be
clear he did this before there was a war
uh with russia donald trump did whereas
biden just said he was he's been working
for months after these attacks
our forces are not
disengaged
we will not engage in the conflict with
russian forces in ukraine conflict our
forces are not going to europe to fight
ukraine but to defend our nato allies in
the event that putin decides to keep
moving west
for that purpose i mean the allies who
spent less than one percent of the gdp
guess what they should not be defended
at all nato countries including enjoy
your socialized healthcare
lithuanian estonia and dying and as i've
made crystal clear the united states and
our allies will defend every inch of
territory that is nato territory for the
full force of our collective power hey
how about nato protects every inch of
nato yeah how about the rest of the nato
nations protect
their own nation how about when the
ukraine gave up i said it how about
ukraine giving up their nuclear missiles
and we're like hey don't worry we'll be
there so under trump nato allies
increase your spending by 50 billion
just to be clear only two other
countries even paid two percent of the
promised amount that was greece in the
uk and who cares about greece that's
just a few lesbians on an island on the
battlefield
he'll pay a continuing high price over
the long run
and a pound of ukrainian people
proud proud people
fight with every inch of energy they
have
they've known 30 years of independence a
pound of ukrainians
a pound of ukrainian people in the hand
there's three russians in a bush yep
i'll be honest with you as they're
always promised
a russian dictator i can kill two birds
and i'm always stoned yeah has cost
around the world huh
and i'm taking robust action to make
sure the pain of our sanctions is
targeted at russian accounts doctors are
the size of a graveyard and that we use
every tool
to protect american businesses and
consumers
tonight
i can announce the united states has
worked with 30 other countries to
release 60 million barrels of oil from
reserves around the world
how about oil in the united states why
do we need any oil from around the world
keep in mind he's the one who shut down
the keystone pipeline immediately for
the first time ever in modern american
history under donald trump we were a net
neck supporter of uh net next board now
this is what happened we have a net
exporter of oil in 2016. lewis 2016
maybe was 2019 and then we went right
back he's the one who approved the
nordstrom 2 pipeline going through
russia why do we need anyone else's oil
it's clear that we don't we're going to
be okay well i feel like everybody there
drives gas cars because nobody stood for
that will have left russia weaker
and the rest of the world stronger
you guys checking his phone
it's like
you got some text from his wife can you
bring home eggs ah
man [ __ ] won't leave me alone
hey by the way they just said that the
60 million barrels of oil have been
released that sounds like a lot we use
20.6 million barrels a day in the united
states yes yeah so that's three days joe
thanks by the way keep in mind if we
drilled and fracked more here guess what
we could provide people in europe
including the ukraine with more oil hey
america first helps the country first
unbelievable we see unity but your
auction mask on first and you should
know about that with his cpap crowds
around the world even in russia
to demonstrate their support for the
people of ukraine
in the battle between democracy and
autocracies
democracies are rising into the night
six months ago and the world is clearly
choosing the side of peace and security
this is the real test
and it's going to take time
so let us continue to draw inspiration
from the irony
they're being attacked right now fellow
ukrainian americans
who forge the deep bond that connects
our two nations
we stand with charisma we stand that was
stephen king putin may circle keeve with
tanks
but he'll never gain the hearts and
souls of the iranian people the iranians
did he just say iranian yes
that's like finish your beer we can't
but
you should he just said iranian oh no
well you know that we don't go into
enough countries when you just throw out
next he calls them the yemen people oh
shoot i hate don't tip your hand joe why
are you giving a standing small well's
like waving the flag yes yeah yes he's
just waving the chinese spy's panties
this nation has ever faced yes because
you're here
we're the iraqis and so many families
that are living paycheck to paycheck
you're mailing it to food gas housing
and so much more
i understand like many of you did
my dad had to leave his home in scranton
pennsylvania to find work
so like many of you i grew up in a
family when the price of food went up it
was felt throughout the family yeah 7.5
inflation in the first quarter i believe
in 2021
let's fight to pass the american rescue
plan
because
i think it's this year yeah we needed to
act
full few pieces of legislation have done
more at a critical moment in our history
to lift us out of a crisis
it fueled our efforts to vaccinate the
nation and combat coven-19
delivered immediate economic relief to
tens of millions of americans
that helped put food on the table
remember those long lines of cars
waiting for hours just to get a box of
food put in their trunk
it cut the cost of health care insurance
and as my dad used to say it gave the
people just a little bit of breathing
room
he used to say unlike the two trillion
dollar taxes passed in the previous
administration
the benefit of this is he talking about
jimmy carter gas lines
tax cuts
oh look at him
oh my gosh
he's basically saying that tax cuts
under trump were bad right yeah i know
they worked yeah even though we had
record low unemployment we had crazy
high labor force participation
apparently it benefited black americans
more than your you know your former
buddy over there and uh right now we
have record high inflation we have no
new net added jobs keep in mind zero
zero jobs have been added since the high
of 2019 before the democrats decided to
uh ensure that uh a pandemic was thrust
upon the world and of course it was
covered up that china might have known
more than they did so less than one yeah
more jobs
in one year
if you fire everybody right and then
hire eight people it's an eight percent
increase yes
they're the strongest growth rate in 40
years good god the first step in
bringing fundamental changes
too long
for the past 40 years
we were told
the tax break for those of the top and
benefits would trickle down and everyone
would benefit but that trickle-down
theory led to a weaker economic growth
lower wages bigger deficits and a
winding gap between the top
and everyone else and then the average
household income
in the first three years of donald trump
we can factor this and bring it up i'm
going by was over 5 000
a year under eight years of obama it was
about eleven hundred yeah three years of
donald trump you've never seen those
kinds of that's across the board okay
just to be clear when he talks about how
it didn't trickle down when he talks
about how there was a widening gap
between the wealthy no the gap widened
between the wealthy and the rest of you
with covid the top five companies in the
world added over two trillion dollars
to their to their ledgers because we
know when the middle class grows
when the middle class grows the poor of
a way up and the wealthy do very well
america used to have the best roads
bridges and airports on earth because
they were man and now
our infrastructure is ranked 13th in the
world infrastructure
won't be able to compete for the jobs of
the 21st century if we don't fix it
that's why i was so impressed they're
doing such a great job secretary of
transport
accurate part of that name is secretary
clinton
he wears that badge with honor he should
be called dottie and fixing people their
their lunch cocktails could i have a
softer chair
single biggest investor anybody have a
doubt but i have an inner tube
it's a bipartisan effort and i want to
thank the members of both parties who
work to make it happen
we're done talking about infrastructure
weeks we're now talking about an
infrastructure decade
infrastructure
drink bring back up the drinking rules
for people who haven't seen them yet
again use the promo code biden fact
check or the biden fact check hashtag
sotu state of the union to put us on a
path to win the economic competition of
the 21st century that we face with the
rest of the world particularly china
oh i've told xi jinping
it's never been a good bet to bet
against the american people
really will create good jobs
america he said no no no no no no no no
no no just bet against you that's
america not american people no no no no
no just you you withstand the
devastating effects of climate change
looks like he's part of justice
we'll build a national network of 500
charging stations
begin to replace the poisonous lead
pipes so every child every american has
clean water to drink at home and at
school yeah you said you just talked
about building electric vehicle charging
stations hey hey hold on former vice
president joe biden how are you going to
charge them dick
[Applause]
hey remember when you visited flint
that's still a problem
and tribal communities
four thousand projects have already been
announced
many of you have announced them in your
districts
and tonight
i'm announcing that this year
we will start fixing over
nightmares here one
thousand five hundred bridges
i'm sorry but talking about
infrastructure when the world is on fire
i get that it's important but maybe not
tonight no let's be honest pipes aren't
that important
and private companies can do it better
that was green energy and infrastructure
oh shut up
i need another beer in america somebody
in the studio buy american products by
the way the america competes bill just
to give you some quick facts just so you
know the main focus of the bill is
engineering biology this is from
congress.gov 50 billion in subsidies for
the semiconductor industry with no
guardrails to prevent any funding
actually going to china 78 billion to
the national science foundation that is
uh completely unrelated to china 8
billion for the un green climate fund it
expands the federal government into
education creates apprenticeship
programs to edge out private businesses
it calls for more federal money to k-12
education there's just so much in here
that has nothing to do yeah with making
america more common at all everything
from the deck of an aircraft carrier to
the steel on highway guard rails is made
in america from beginning to end all of
it all of it
two ways to do that
make this a more business-friendly
economy donald trump or number two force
american companies to do it which just
ends up uh
resulting with more of them shut up yes
we also need to leverage the field
with china
and other competitors how do we do that
joe that's why it's so important to pass
the bipartisan innovation act sitting in
congress that will make record
investments in emerging technologies in
american manufacturing
we used to invest almost two percent of
our gdp in research
to invest we don't now you meant to say
we is to invest because it was looking
at clarence thomas we used one example
why it's so important to pass
we don't now if you travel 20 miles east
of columbus ohio
you'll find a thousand empty acres of
land
it won't look like much it isn't much if
you stop and look closely
you'll see a field of dreams
in which america's future and if you
build it they'll come
that's where intel there's silicon
valley
is going to build a 20 billion
semiconductor mega site
up to eight state-of-the-art factories
in one place
ten thousand new jobs
in those factories the average job of
about 135 dollars why is old kevin klein
there was a year
sometimes greg
[Laughter]
computer chips assigned behind all the
power of the world in everyday lives
from smartphones technology the the
internet technology has yet to be
invented kevin costner but that's just
the beginning
intel ceo pat gelsinger who's here
tonight i know where pat is pat there
you go pat you looked right to him you
had no idea what it was did you that's
like baby geniuses yeah
thank you for coming harry
[Laughter]
thank you i came from hogwarts
hey pat say hello i wasn't i wasn't
expecting to speak he's that guy from
short circuits yes to 100 shouldn't you
be filming a shriners commercial the
biggest investment in manufacturing in
american history they accidentally cut
to them
40 days
oh yes so let's not wait any longer
send it to my desk i'll sign it
and we'll really take off in a big way
really by the way his desk is fisher
price yes
no i just got one from putin it's really
long now
that guy was actually 60.
no no the the guy on the
shriners commercial it's 140 yards
the rebirth of pride the company
stamping products made in america the
revitalization of american manufacturing
companies are choosing to build new
factories here
you're trying to force them to go
overseas no american manufacturing
boomed under donald trump is investing
11 billion in electric vehicles creating
11 000 jobs across the country how are
you going to power the electric vehicles
when the government forces elect modern
electric vehicles guess what it look
green energy companies don't work when
they're forced in by the government look
at elon musk get to leave california
you're talking about millions of jobs
and businesses that have had to leave
california not to mention the toyota
headquarters they're doing electric
vehicles why wouldn't they be doing that
in california eco-friendly elon musk
went to texas texas is more friendly to
environmentally friendly jobs than
california it's we we all want cleaner
energy yours just doesn't work
who's here tonight where are you jojo
there you go thanks buddy
ohio
as ohio senator pull himself up
he's like he's like i'm just the postman
he's a trainer not that kind of trainer
though the janitor from rudy
[Laughter]
oh look he's sitting next to the guy
they showed earlier
it's time
to sign
the
[Music]
in our economy
job growth higher wages too many
families are struggling to keep up with
their bills yeah inflation see you never
mind is robbing them of gains
okay
that's why my top priority is getting
prices under control
problem our economy roared back faster
than almost anyone predicted nope but
pandemic that businesses zero hard time
hiring people from the 2019 she still
had a deduction
not one
so you didn't have people making those
beams that went in the buildings because
they were out he just said beans that
went into buildings beans yeah he said
beans
global supply chain you get a point for
not saying
are these beans when that happens it
takes longer to make goods and get them
to the warehouses to the stores
let's make a conservative argument now
inflation affects everything including
americans at the pump and including
everything that needs to be shipped
right something that we've talked about
in the past that's why we should be more
dependent on our own oil and natural gas
reserves he's making that case and then
he's going to say by the way that means
that the government who printed more
money the government who devalued the
dollar the government decided to create
record high unemployment and cur
which
inflation scenario we're going to fix it
how mandates
i think i have a better idea to fight
inflation yeah let's hear it lower your
cost not your wages
i'm sorry
yeah that's the solution when businesses
right now have been shuttering in record
levels do you think restaurants right
now who are coming yeah let's just lower
our costs there's some iranian who he
supports like i'm still sitting on on
like five pounds of shrimp that hasn't
been used you know what happens when you
lower costs
more profit
you don't typically lower your price as
well you idiot in america well we're
paying more for cheese and pepperoni and
such what do you think we should do
lower prices
make it in america
what do you want to do after that i
don't know shoot myself and my whole
family
i got time on my hands
starting with you jill she's just like
oh boy
i quit my corporate job in 2019 to
follow this dream
[Applause]
hey jill what happens when you mix red
and blue we're going to be looking
turquoise after tonight
what double belt shotgun well and you by
the way you're right seven and a half
percent inflation at the end of twenty
twenty one carry end of 2021 january
2022. i think overall it's been over six
percent under his presidency there's no
what are we going into march
nine
nine are we nine for real no i'm just
kidding we'll see let's see all right
let's lower the deficit
seventeen nobel laureates in economics
said my plan will ease long-term
inflationary pressures
top business leaders
and i believe most americans support the
plan and here's the plan that's wrong
first
cut the cost of prescription drugs
hey didn't donald trump wasn't he the
first president in modern history let's
fact check this to actually cut the cost
of prescription drugs he was the first
president to do that
they've all run on it they've all run on
it donald trump did it
just look at insulin
one in ten americans has diabetes i
wonder virginia i met a 13 year old boy
the handsome young man standing up there
joshua davis
he and his dad both had type 1 diabetes
which means they need insulin every
single day
insulin cost about 10 dollars a vial to
make
that's what it costs
the pharmaceutical company
but drug companies charge families like
joshua and his dad up to 30 times that
amount hey how much did you give to
pfizer
how many hundreds of millions of dollars
were given from this government to
pharmaceutical companies by the way with
carte blanche no requirement to pay back
the american people for footing the bill
and by the way reduce liability so you
can't sue them when damage is done oh
now we're back to vilifying
pharmaceutical companies they're making
money on other drugs okay i understand i
just want to make sure i understand the
rule book see remember i talked about
this money uh this monday this is what
happened with already drinking the
drinking game i'm sounding like a former
vice president joe biden talked about
this monday it is entirely inconsistent
to vilify pharmaceutical companies and
then support the course of action that
you've seen from this presidency in
former vice presidency with the vaccines
and 200 000 other young people with type
1 diabetes
let's capture the cost of insulin
buying that at 10 so then they can sell
it to people that are sick and needed to
live at 300 times the cost
because of him and because of really
clinton who lacks the drug laws to begin
with and insurance companies yes because
now there's so much red tape they have
to charge you so much because they have
to have so many people on staff who by
the way got the biggest kickback in the
history of mankind insurance companies
in the history of insurance companies
under obamacare
they all ready are you going to throw up
the price for va drugs
no goodness look the american rescue
plan is helping millions of families
with affordable care act plans to save
them twenty four hundred dollars a year
on their health for premiums let's close
the
gap and make these savings permanent
what happened he said premium
investment tax credits to weatherize
your home
and your
to be energy efficient and get a tax
credit for it
double america's clean energy production
and so i thought you were just upset
about tax breaks
i will say this though credit to her
makeup artist they definitely made her
eyes look less googly
that's true gee i sure hope her
boyfriend's feet are there
[Applause]
you just want to have sex with exactly
anything we can do to change the
standard of living for hardworking folks
is cut the cost of child care
hey how about you make it so they don't
have to pay for child care because
everything's so expensive and they have
to work double triple shifts dummy
let the government raise your kids
forever
hey guys out there i've run out i need
to give me a devil's backbone i'll need
something stiffer
i was a single dad for five years
raising two kids had a lot of help
though what
i had a mom a dad he was a singer
his wife passed away i didn't know that
middle class and working folks
shouldn't have to pay more than seven
percent of their income to care for the
young children
my plan
i mean hunter killed it hey by the way
do you know where that money comes from
they're gonna take all of your money and
use that
it helped that's past millions of women
who left the workforce during the
pandemic because they were giving them
child care
i thought it was to be able to get back
to work
wrong one generating economic growth
but my plan doesn't stop there it also
includes home and long-term care you
wouldn't know economic growth if it bit
you on the sterile scrotum
all these were lower costs for
hemisphere of your brain nobody let me
say this again nobody earning less than
four hundred thousand dollars a year
will pay an additional penny in new tax
hey by the way can we fact checks what
is the exact presidential salary yeah
don't you love that he's like oh
400 000 yeah that's the magic number
like hey maybe we should make it so only
people under over 300 000 should pay
more no
does that include bonuses
no gifts present tax system
ain't fair how about insider trading oh
god we have to throw he's going into
russia to get changed
here
well let's make corporations and wealthy
americans start paying their fair share
oh the fair share argument ah okay okay
let the americans pay 27 times hey
there's a pocahontas oh it's an old stat
so it's probably more now define fair
share joe tom he's thinking my golden
retriever could give a better speech
than this oh yeah
we come from the land of corporate
america there you go
400 americans and every other state in
america combined
and i still won 36 years in a row
the point is huh even they understand
they should pay just a fair share what's
that last year
55 of the fortune 500 companies
earned 40 billion dollars in profit and
paid zero can we bring up that fact
check guys in the under the pandemic the
top five or top 10 wealthiest americans
are the top companies what they they're
not
worth i believe it was or their assets
increased two billion dollars you don't
need to do that given have them send it
the control room to you that's the
problem right when you have a
fundamentally controlled economy right a
manipulated economy guess what
the big guys when why do you think big
banks support democrats why do you think
apple amazon google youtube twitter
facebook all of these companies support
democrats when you again it's
inconsistent to try and say oh corporate
interests but then not recognize that
the most powerful companies that have
ever existed oil companies no not even
close support what he's saying because
they make more money it hurts
middle-sized businesses it hurts small
businesses and everybody knows it you
can look at the numbers all references
is available at loudoscada.com bring it
up we all know we've got to make changes
it
changes
who has to make changes
well he has to get changed typo
go to an intermission and just a bunch a
bunch of depends let's go to the lobby
what do you mean get off which plays it
get up xanax and alcohol and everything
else
for two
years only lower cost and give worried
about everything losing their lives
where's the deficit yeah we only need to
change this administration not only the
deficit with those tax cuts for the very
wealthy corporations oh he's going to
lower it it
undermined the watchdogs
the job of those to keep pandemic relief
funds being wasted remember we had those
debates speaking of which is your dog
still inviting everybody who takes a
white house tour
how much money was being spent where was
it going to the right place so
kind of my administration
the watchdogs are back
silver thing on her desk
billions of relief money
meant for small business and millions of
americans tonight i'm announcing that
the justice department will soon name a
chief prosecutor for pandemic fraud
ah
so how about this uh former vice
president you first
hey does f is fauci on that list when he
said yeah it occurred in nature it did
not come from the wuhan lab is that is
that by the end of this year the depths
will be down to less interest
the only president ever to cut the
deficit by more than one trillion
dollars in a single year that's cool
true at all lowering your cost also
meant demanding more competition
did you just clearly lower the deficit
by one trillion
will by the end of this year oh okay
capitalism without competition she was
like one billion
that's not the number we discussed
what was the number we discussed uh
negative trillion compete
their profits go up and your prices go
up and they don't have to compete look
nancy pelosi
guess what
you got four basic meat packing
facilities uh-huh that's it
butt gate just stood up at attention
what
i lot more sorry did you say packers
there's only four
see what's happening with ocean carriers
and moving goods in and out of america
during the pandemic
yeah he's showing with me back
after all the companies prices
profits
tonight
i'm announcing a crackdown on those
companies overcharging american
businesses and consumers
hey don't you see this all of this is
punishing american businesses who he's
harmed and accepting no responsibility
you just deciding nebulously they're
over charging yeah why did prices all of
a sudden go up and why did it happen to
coincide with record inflation gas
prices unemployment you think it's just
because they decided they could screw
people who by the way couldn't pay those
fees anyway
it's as stupid as the idea of predatory
lending
homes but and make sure your loved ones
get together people are going to
restaurants because the prices are too
high
we're also going to cook efforts to keep
the economy going strong and giving
workers a fair shot
so new york wasn't because you put the
tables out in the street and people were
getting hit by
degrees
let's pass the paycheck fairness act and
paid me
raise the minimum wage to 15
it's already 50. dunkin donuts right
down the street right now is paying 15
an hour to start no one has to raise the
family in poverty
oh because 15 an hour is not poverty 30k
is all it takes for you to raise a
family joe
you know what jesus mcdonald's down the
street that paid more than hitmen made
in the 80s america's best kept secret
well the best
accepted it wasn't timothy
i'm not saying stop let's pass the pro
number he's proud of the crime but
that's what he's saying right now here's
what he's saying i'll sum it up for you
the government knows best and we're
going to send money from your paycheck
to everybody by the way have you seen
the fight for 15 organization now they
did it they planned to strike for 25 oh
20 all mcdonald's workers guys bring
that up there was a there was a flyer
being passed out for all mcdonald's
workers to strike until they got 25 an
hour because guess what happens with
inflation your money you just need to
you just need to pay more
15 an hour is not what it would have
been yeah last year
who sit at a dining room table or a
kitchen table and look at an empty chair
yeah yours because they lost somebody
is he faking i also know this
because of the progress we've made
because of your resiliency more people
and the tools that we have been provided
by this congress the vaccine that you
said you wouldn't take that one moving
forward
safely
back to a no no
where severe cases are down the level
not seen since july of last year
just a few days ago the center for
disease control and prevention
issued a new mass guideline well the
eighth one is more abundant
most americans
and most of the country
can now go mask free we've been doing
that for
you
but you say that like it's a good thing
[Applause]
you have guys in masks there so you can
say how are we mask free look to your
right and left we've made in the past
year cover 19 no longer needs to control
our lives
i know some are talking about living
with covet 19. but tonight i say
that we never will just accept living
with cover 19. oh please don't continue
to combat the virus
as we do other diseases
and because this virus mutates and
spreads we have to stay on guard which
means you live here here are four common
sense steps now you're backfired safely
first
stay protected with vaccinations
shouldn't have taken that circular logic
course in politically effective vaccines
are you know
will never give up on vaccinating more
americans all right drink now i know
kids under five are eager to see their
vaccines authorized by the way no no
we're not kids under five no working
hard to get that done by the way the cdc
was held
the vaccine effectiveness the data on it
with the boosters ages 18 to 40 let
alone what we don't know anything with
people who are five years old when the
cdc first published a significant that
we have this in the new york times
overlay significant data on the
effectiveness of boosters and adults
younger than 65 two weeks ago but left
out the numbers for a huge portion of
that population 18 to 49 year olds the
group least likely to benefit from extra
shots and by the way there's a curve
where people who are least likely to
benefit from shots people who get
younger we don't even have the data on
five-year-olds because it's [ __ ]
initiative
so people can get tested at a pharmacy
and if they prove positive receive the
anti-viral pills on the spot hey who's
generating the testing kits joe who's
generating the who's generating the
boosters the pharmaceutical companies
you just vilified
yeah for insulin
there's nothing consistent about it you
can't be consistent do they have to
release the data 75 years from now still
or can we get it maybe next week i don't
know he's planning on all of us being
free behold in the skynet we're leaving
no one behind or ignoring women's needs
as we move forward
on testing
we've made hundreds of millions of tests
available and you can order them for
free to your doorstep
and we've already ordered free tests if
you're already ordered free tests
tonight uh sorry we've just been
notified that there is a delivery fee
due to the increasing gas prices yeah
go to coventest.gov just stumbled next
week and you can get you order them
tonight you can get them eight years
after
very exciting over the past we've gotten
much better at detecting newton's
looking at this lint what the hell is
this
couldn't have worn that ukrainian scarf
that's it with cheap scars for years i
thought it looks good and if congress
presides the funds
players were innocent stockpiles of
tests mass pills ready if needed
i can't promise a new variant won't come
but i can't i can't promise you what
we'll do everything within our power to
be ready if it does
burn oh so you mean you won't have more
than a hundred thousand people killed uh
on top of trump so donald trump was what
like 420 something thousand and his was
520 something thousand people dying
under his watch under keep in mind the
least deadly variant omicron bill gates
said what i said he said that omicron is
responsible for saving more lives than
the vaccine he said it not us i said it
then bill gates said it yeah we're doing
that here in the first mike
the vast majority of federal workers why
are you trying to get together and work
in person our schools are open let's
keep it that way
our kids need to be in school hey hey
who's been saying that for for several
years everyone's now standing and
clapping yes school should stay open oh
really yeah okay new one by the way i
just see that one lady in red she's
wearing a tarp
yes
seventy-five percent of the volunteers
and hospitalizations down by
seventy-seven percent
oh can remove their mass
and stay in the classroom he reached in
the wrong pockets he reached his pocket
for a mask did you see that he reached
one point the other pocket
that's certainly a flub he thought he
had a mask of course gallagher didn't
bring out his watermelon so i'll not
surprise you i'll be back to see you
where's my mouth i'm going to assume
congress
the vast majority of americans have used
these tools and they won again
no they said jews and easter so i expect
congress and i hope you'll pass that
quickly what fourth huh we'll continue
vaccinating the world and b
we've sent 475 million vaccine doses
to 112 countries why any nation
why
pelosi seems fairly alert and by the way
don't you love that we scent
no you gave that money to a private
company who developed it by the way a
vaccine that you said you wouldn't trust
and you wouldn't take all three of them
on that stage that there's no way we
would get a vaccine within two years
that they wouldn't trust if it was
developed under donald trump and they
wouldn't take it you gave that money to
a private company by the way privatizing
profits because the american taxpayers
don't get a share of those profits and
then that company
sent it overseas
that's a partisan dividing line oh see
it for what it is
a god-awful disease
that was christian descending seeing
each other as enemies really start
seeing each other for who we are
enemies fellow americans no you sold
them to the americans no they pushed
that for a year and a half and they have
said everything they can to make you
hate here's the problem no we have
enemies it's called china they lied
about it fouchy knew about it fauci also
hit it and fouchy also threatened other
doctors who tried to point out his lies
we have these emails
we have enemies there's nothing look we
have plenty of friends we could use a
few enemies we're looking at you wuhan
kovid 19 generating lab
i recently visited new york city police
department days after the funerals
officer is that before or after you uh
supported people through a molotov
cocktail through their precinct said
awesome
to himself out of a dui
officer moore was 27 years old officer
vera was 22 years old
both dominican-americans who grew up in
the same streets
that they later chose the parole to
patrol as police officers
they were dominated and they could have
related
for their sacrifices
and will carry on their mission to
restore the trust and safety in every
community deserves
what like some of you have been around
for a while
i've worked with you on these issues for
a long time what you worked with the
party who said defund the police you son
of a [ __ ]
the one behind you said to keep doing it
we know the neighborhood raised money
for serial rapists and felons and their
gofundme
we're choosing to bang the mayor and
equal justice
let's come together and protect our
communities restore trust and hold law
enforcement accountable i just wanted to
put us out that's why the justice
department has required body cameras
banned choke calls and restricted no
knox warrants for its officers
that's why the americans and chokeholds
because i'm sure the purpose prefer
billy club provided 350 billion dollars
that cities states and counties can use
to hire more police invest in more
proven strategies well pelosi is praying
to george floyd right now too so yes
that's true thank you george floyd
he's looking down at the clap break yes
where do i clap again can i join
through peppermint schnapps
interruption trusted messenger breaking
the cycle of violence just as a triple
sec patch
oh
oh really it's to fund the police whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what
did you say the answer is not to defund
the police the answer is to fund the
police and kamala harris just stood for
that yeah hold on a second you have
someone who encouraged people to
continue rioting behind him and you have
a lady who prayed to the deity of george
floyd stand for funding the police more
are you you are are you starting to get
the picture democrats and republicans
alike to pass you guys out to keep our
neighborhood safe well kamala's pissed
she's like
i can't believe you made me stand for
that [ __ ]
i'm looking forward to finding the
police ice cream assemble at home
because that's what i'm just waiting i'm
just waiting for blower kamala hey joe
shut up
and measure do you know what we said it
wasn't that long universal background
you're making us look like an [ __ ]
on the terrorists in the tupac in the
70s
that's a weird clap you think do you
think if you get it closer to him he can
hear him he's going after the second
amendment okay here we go he's using it
she's in church thank you thank you
watching us for speaking in tongues at
least the ball fell off her nose you
think the deer wearing kevlar vests no i
think that russia might invade joe
manufactures the only industry in
america that can't be sued the only one
that's not true that's vaccine companies
dumb ass had we done that with the
tobacco manufacturers
and tobacco lives
hold on a second guys i have to fact
remind me to come back to the suing of
gun companies and comparing it to the
vaccine companies because yeah he lied
vaccine companies can't be so the
manufacturers of vaccines and the
difference is those can cause direct
harm gun companies can be sued if a guy
purchased a gun from a local gun shop
and then sue walther smith and wesson
ruger even though that's not what it was
designed for whereas a vaccine can be
designed to be injected into someone's
body cause direct damage and they can't
be sued okay let's go to act
past the john lewis act voting rights
when michael moore blames kmart for
columbine right right pass the disclose
act so americans know who's funding our
election
look yeah yeah you know what you first
teachers unions
advisor dedicated pharmaceutical
companies country
justice briar
an army veteran he's ice cream
constitutional scholar very bad retiring
justice united
[Applause]
we're going to have somebody just like
you except not at all like you replace
you he looks like a ladybug who lost her
shell
oh thank you so much it's been great oh
i love it oh my god i had no idea brian
was gay
he's like a gay man this has been
inconceivable
you just see pete butt king's head pop
up what
the united states supreme court but
sitting next to him now here we go as i
did four days ago here we go i've
nominated the circuit court of appeals
katangi brown tangy
[Applause]
i'm sorry hold on you said top legal
mind i thought you said you were going
to nominate a black female well that can
be a topic yeah but he didn't say that
when he said he was going to nominate
somebody well i know he should have said
both family of public school educators
and police officers
she's a consensus
she's been nominated she's received a
broad range of support
including the fraternal order of police
oh and former judges by the way
this broad he's talking about 2001
jackson co-authored an amicus brief in a
support of a law that would actually
stop pro-life activists from speaking to
women outside of abortion oh really from
speaking to women outside of abortion
right that's it
no just talking signs
this is someone who actively has fought
against first amendment rights if you
don't like people who are pro-life fine
if you actually believe that you should
ban people from speaking outside of
abortion clinics
then you don't believe in the first
amendment this is the broad he chose
we've installed new technology like
cutting edge scanners or we moved on
quickly from the supreme court nominee
want to know why shut up because that's
all you can read in her resume on
guatemala to catch more human
traffickers
we're putting in place dedicated
immigration judges a significant larger
number so families fleeing persecution
and violence can have their curses cases
heard faster than those who don't
legitimately play the calligraphy uh
we're securing signatures and supporting
partners in south and central america to
host more refugees and secure their own
borders
we can do all this we'll get right on
that the torch of liberty those led the
generation of immigrants to this land
my four years and many of yours
provide a pathway to citizens
statue of liberty like it's like it's a
bug zapper farmworkers
[Applause]
farm workers essential workers i mean do
you hear them
he called immigrants farm workers
that's all they are to do joe decades
reunite
it's not only the right thing to do it's
an economical smart thing to
you use the n do
like nine times
labor unions the religious leaders to
the us in the context you don't want to
let's get it done
context doesn't matter unless it's
anywhere else
folks
we've already done this before by the
way that's his cue folks is for them to
stand the diabetes kid is like my foot
hurts liberty and justice also requires
protecting the rights of women
a constitutional right affirmed by roe v
wade standing president for half a
century is under attack as never before
damn straight it is you want to go
forward not backwards we must protect
access to health care preserve a woman's
right to choose what does roe v wade
have to do with health care the right to
choose it's about some arbitrary
interpretation of the right to privacy
ruth bader ginsburg said that and that's
why she didn't support it dummy but you
were going to say that's why she died
gbtq plus americans oh let's finally get
the bipartisan equality
to my desk
yes yes right now in this economy the
most important thing is that a man in a
mustache and muumuu can take a [ __ ] at a
target
but what about that last year especially
to our younger transgender person i'll
always have your back in your beatles
outfit so you can be yourself
and reach your god-given potential
it's not god-given
it's surgeon-giving
[Applause]
it took away what god gave you and you
put a strap on there
just demonstrated yeah
we do agree on a lot more things than we
acknowledge nope no
i signed 80 bipartisan bills in the law
last year didn't read a one
from preventing government shutdowns
protecting asian americans from still to
common hate crimes so asian conforming
military
agent americans and we'll assume
asian and haitian i think three decades
ago you heard asian americans and you're
thinking about
the bill he wrote three decades ago
they'll take out the n word that he used
several times right
that's good scratch that he's a used
white house which is in fact the name of
the bill yeah tonight i'm offering a
unity agenda for the nation okay let's
see this four big things we can do
together i love you
first
beat the opioid
epidemic
well you have to talk to your son
he's porting them start with your own
family the ones pharmaceuticals are bad
and now pharmaceuticals
enforcement to go after illegal
immigrants
from addiction hills that are filled
with fentanyl that aren't even the drugs
that they're supposed to be i believe in
recovery and i celebrate the 23 minutes
little charm for your brother worked
like a charm for his son
[Applause]
especially among our vice presidents
among our children who we mask and
scared the [ __ ] out of for two years
i urge every parent
to make sure your school your school
does just that they have the money
we can all play a part
sign up to be a tutor
and we had a record number of teen
suicides in the history of the united
states by the way and depression and
generalized anxiety disorders so okay
all right
who is here tonight with us has shown
we must hold social media platforms
accountable and michael phelps for the
national experiment they're conducting
on our children
oh don't you love this this is someone
who worked at facebook and now what
she's working with the government oh
okay yeah she was a whistleblower yeah
but not the way you'd think no
[Applause]
ban targeted advertising to children
demand tech coming stop collecting
personal data on our children
and let's get all americans the mental
health services they need
more people
let's start with you and some levidopa
and the full parity between physical
you notice he said that every time
there's a clap there's a cue it's either
look or folks yeah it's super poor at
our veterans
[Applause]
what did pelosi just fall forward
did she did she have to po did she have
to post can we drink her yeah
that was an excited clap too much rum in
the room raising
those we send the war by the way also
for no regular family
i'll take rumbles minus the balls
and job training houses and now helping
lower incomes
save them from me and our troops in iraq
have faced afghanistan faced many
dangers yeah they did one being
stationed at bases breathing in toxic
smoke from burn pits why is she clapping
for that what the [ __ ] what
because she's drunk and hazards material
and so much more
dude she wants to come home
like she did it like she was a fly on
[ __ ]
in the world
[Laughter]
she's the lady from christmas vacation
right now
all right sorry hold on
flashlight she wraps up her cat it's
fine just go in the other room i know
how much you want to bet she brought a
jello mold to this
for sure one of those
one of those
i don't know for sure if the burn pit
that he lived near that his hooch was
near
in iraq and earlier did you say that
because brain cancer i don't know what
that means
but i am committed
to find out everything we can
committed
to military families like danielle
robinson from ohio
the widow of sergeant first class heath
robinson
he was born a soldier
army national guard
combat medic in kosovo in iraq
stationed near baghdad just yards from
burn pits the size of football fields
danielle is here with us tonight
they love going to ohio state football
games
look i'm so and obviously your heart
goes out to any veteran
god bless your husband for serving the
fact that he's now talking about burn
pits and ohio state football games tells
you how paper thin he spent less than
maybe we can bring it 20 seconds on the
supreme court nominee yeah and he spent
less than two minutes on the actual
economy cancer from prolonged exposure
to ravaged speaking from someone whose
family is still waiting on that says
good luck as a fighter to the very end
kidding
he didn't
stop fighting wholeheartedly to that
family yeah neither did she serve
through her pain
to demand that we do better
tonight danielle we are going to do
better
the va
the va is firing new ways of linking
toxic exposure to disease
already helping more
veterans get benefits and tonight
i'm announcing we're expanding
eligibility to veterans suffering from
nine respiratory cancers
i'm also calling unconscious apply to
those who took the vaccine make sure
veterans devastated by toxic exposure in
iraq and afghanistan finally get the
benefits and the comprehensive vietnam
joe
yeah maybe you want to go back to that
one or you can still be waiting a lot of
people yeah
i'd be for that yeah sign that bill
tomorrow baby yeah there's one i should
know you are in politics then yes
you could have done something about it
then and now right
let's end cancer
mid-50s oh wait
let's just personally
let's end cancer as we know it look they
just looked down let's here
it says clap
is cancer bad
i think so is it in ukraine it says
sorry i wasn't as excited as i was to
stand up for the burns
cancer just doesn't get me as enthused
many at the tennis club i throw up so
many of you you've lost someone you love
husband wife son daughter mom dad
they're watching
cancer is the number two cause of death
in america second only to heart disease
yeah copenhagen's last month
i announced the plan to supercharge the
cancer moonshot that president obama
asked me to lead six years ago
our goal is to cut cancer death rates
at least 50 over the next 25 years i
think we can do better than that
turn cancers from death sentences into
treatable diseases
more support for patients and their
families
who's going to do that right those evil
pharmaceutical companies i just want to
make sure that's
advanced
advanced research
projects agency for health
pattern after darpan the defense
department
here's the thing this sounds good do you
really believe the government
they couldn't figure out that kovid came
from the covid named lab
john stewart had to tell them
well it sounds good until you can buy
stock
to drive breakthroughs in cancer
alzheimer's and diabetes well that
second one is certainly it's been a rush
order for you
we can do these things it's within our
power
and i don't see a partisan edge to any
one of those forces really
my fellow americans
tonight how much you want to bet he
walked into that office he's like i want
to care for alzheimer's
space
a citadel of democracy
in this capital
generation after generation americans
have debated great questions
amid great strife
and i've done great things he's
definitely did you say made great strife
experience he meant to say make great
strides
in fairness that was a freudian right we
built the strongest
freest and most prosperous nation the
world has ever known you're trying to
tear it down did you say we broke the
most prosperous nation built our moment
of responsibility
our tested resolve and conscience
of history itself
it is in this moment
that our character of this generation is
formed
our purpose is found horrible character
our future is forged
well i know this
i nation no knack protect freedom and
liberty
expand fairness and opportunity
and we will save democracy
as hard as those times have been i'm
more optimistic about american democracy
he said it was the free
because i know there's simply nothing
beyond our commas our capacity oh yeah
we're the only nation
or damascus every crisis
the only nation that can be defined by a
single word possibilities
so on this night
on our 245th year as a nation pushed in
front of a train i've come to report on
the state of the nation the state of the
union and my report is this
the state of the union is strong because
you the american people are strong
and i am not
exactly our government's not doing this
any favors thank god you are strong yes
thank god you're strong because i'm very
feeble
and my heart is run by wires and bent
back paper clips
i have pool cues on each side of my
shoes duct taped to keep my knees
as one people one america the united
states of america
god bless you all
and may god protect our troops
thank you
huh
go get him huh go get him go get him he
said go get him
by the way he didn't say god bless
america he said god bless you and god
protect our troops
oh liver spots back there i really like
gosh tapper says okay let's hear what
tapper says it should be suck two
minutes a very strong beginning
several bipartisan moments of standing
ovations
for the people of ukraine seven times he
forgot who he was
lots of applause for holding putin and
russian oligarchs accountable followed
by a call for his domestic agenda
including traditional biden
calls for infrastructure changes to the
tax code a made in america agenda uh
there was the traditional laundry list
right so hold on really quickly before
we go to cnn's commentary actually uh
again the promo code is biden fact check
okay it's available tonight for the next
24 hours you get 20 off at mug club
where we'll be doing another 45 minutes
of show tonight 45 dollars off you go to
lotto credit.com mug club uh and we also
oh we also have footage actually so some
of you are wondering how did he prepare
for this debate yeah and we actually got
exclusive footage
just to his debate prep actually and
this is two beers in and um
turns out he he brought in
not the big he brought in the second big
guy so here
[Music]
vice president dad are you okay
he didn't even smoke any hunter maybe
it's a contact high i mean infinite
gangster this is some great a jean
maybe his dementia medicine's wearing
off what do you think for saki jawia
[Music]
better go back
he's got to do the state of the union in
a little bit and he's full [ __ ]
[Music]
have you tried hitting him
nah we're not supposed to hit him
anymore one more good bump on the noggin
and it's hello president kamala and
goodbye america
didn't you already sell our secrets to
the chinese
dude shut up not in front of my dad
saki doesn't even know about that
circle back
[Laughter]
oh damn those were my dad's pills
that's why i got the hershey sparks i
thought it was an sti from my dead
brother's wife
don't circle back
don't
i saw you looking down her shirt
while she lay over both casket weeping
[Applause]
nice work jack rabbit
i knew you'd wake the former vice
president up
and now the cheese is all ours
[Music]
well it doesn't seem like the most
it doesn't seem like the most prudent
debate prep uh whatever works right and
we'll get them up don't judge we'll be
taking your chats and also giving a full
wrap-up of course on muggle but we'll be
doing a wrap up here then taking your
chats light with credit.com before we do
that you go to the season really quickly
we've got some dates coming up yeah
that's right dave and i will be on tour
yeah so may 4. so lots of these shows
are already sold out so you really got
to jump on these may 14th tulsa ballroom
in tulsa oklahoma june 18th pike's peak
center in colorado springs okay in
colorado springs okay great yeah go to
the west coast with crowder.com tour all
right right now let's go see how cnn is
kissing his ass as we all know he thinks
about unity but tonight he made it
functional as we all know this idea of a
unity agenda these are not wildly
controversial ideas combating opioids
getting rid of the second amendment
these are the kinds of things that are
going to be very hard for people to
argue against i think that's the phase
yeah unless you ship them across
anderson cooper actually unless you've
spent the last two well i'm sorry five
years destroying unity in this country
it's easy to argue that you don't give a
[ __ ] pardon me about unity
i
next to anderson cooper justice breyer
looks gayer even anderson cooper is like
this is making me uncomfortable this is
excessive traditional state of the union
speech
and what he said i think was showed
resolution showed
determining racial drag i do wonder
anderson whether there should have been
more on foreign policy
more on ukraine maybe not so much for
the allies for whom he has been
supporting and reassuring but for the uh
[Laughter]
[Music]
this man is still walking amongst you
he's still representing you
he was banging a chinese spy just to be
clear there's no snopes there's no
politifact that even says kinda true
it's 100 true and he is within a hairs
distance of the former vice president of
the united states
for crying out loud i don't even know if
he last wiped himself on the curtains
since his most pre most recent session
with a chinese spy
it's fine now he's dating a new russian
girl i hear she's very nice an aircraft
to the united states loves him for the
president it's only because the
ukrainian girls were just they there was
a shortage their freedom versus tyranny
as democracy versus autocracy which is
something that one of you cared about
freedom let's be clear about this he's
talking about a supreme court supreme
court nominee right brown jackson
who signed an amicus brief in 2001 that
banned people from discussing pro-life
options in front of planned parenthood i
can't think of a more blatant violation
of the first amendment as well
so it is just
who's that man i don't know
but your right hand looks like he's
wearing uh hulk hogan's outfit from
tropic the tropic uh down was it tropic
down under thunder
oh thunder
in paradise thunder in paradise
it's so sad that only two of us know
this
is
framed the whole issue
very powerfully that guy yeah he feels
like he's just wait you heard powerful
yeah you were powerful really
putin's like ah
look at that guy putin putin is gonna
have a sore hand from smacking his 190
yard table
but you know
if you have any idea as to the robbing
vascularity of putin's erection right
now
oh it's massive
it's actually lifting the table
of this crisis and it's of course
impossible yeah
unless one can get inside the head of
vladimir putin and events on the ground
will determine it but this is not
deterred a very long time why are you
outside i don't believe you're outside
there's no breath right when dr fauci
was asked about thailand bring him in
you know for ending various measures he
said you don't make the timeline the
virus makes the timeline
quite comfortable we don't make the
timeline here it's a very complicated
international crisis
bring me more beagles she opens his
mouth it's like candyman farewell to the
flesh
i said sandflies not bees
michael clark douglas what
duncan duncan
drink gerald is slurring i didn't slur i
just got the name wrong in fairness it
was the the least dumb slur yeah michael
clark duncan 380 pound black guy michael
douglas guy who got uh hpv going down on
catherine zeta jones that's true true
yeah the best way 100 percent true
before he was married to catherine zeta
jones he sounded like uh you know he
sounded like his dad kirk and spartacus
after he sounded like william willem
dafoe and spider-man i should have never
munched on that spider-man no after he's
like i'm much happier now
he just said worth yeah yes
wear that
required any sacrifice on the part of
americans uh but what he did say is that
i want you to know that we're going to
be okay
oh well that's nice how how are we going
to be okay with weak foreign policies
because he's going
he doesn't they're going to take more of
your money well that doesn't make sense
hey he doesn't get it i mean guys he
doesn't get it admonish him that's going
to make it better he's going to take
more of your money it's not
he's going to print more money leave
weapons in places we should bear
yes come on what did you skip keynesian
economics or kenyan asian i don't care
indonesia it's kind of funny he left a
bunch of weapons in the middle east and
his son left weapons in a trash can
outside of elementary school
they're just good at leaving they just
leave them wherever they are that's
common sense his son left a handgun in a
dumpster at an elementary school and
then his dad said uh hold him hold my
schnapps and he left 10 blackhawks in
afghanistan
can we bring up that tweet you were
showing me you knew it was really
distasteful when they used the fighter
jets that were left to spell out joe
rogan is short in this guy you're like
you're like come on isis one of the
people that i hate the most on this
topic i'm gonna have him bring it up
real quick robert reich right said biden
city you usually shouldn't express any
controversial opinions if your name is
right he shouldn't right perhaps his
entire first term will be remembered for
the measured and powerful way he has
dealt with putin's aggression whoever
imagined this would be a significant
part of biden's legacy are you kidding
me by the way his middle name's third
well i i wanted to know if he was the
third
or not just to be safe how how can you
view that speech and go this is powerful
this is measured right no you have
stopped putin from doing nothing you've
stopped them from doing nothing deciding
now you are driving them into the arms
of china by implementing economic
sanctions look i don't believe i i just
i just don't think that economic
sanctions like that work if it is not
combined with severe military action you
either need to be all in or all out it's
just like a fight you have no business
fighting when people talk about getting
into bar fights on the street it's so
silly because the amount of damage that
can be done the unintended consequences
maybe you just think you're going to
slap somebody around yeah he's out coldy
it's head in the concrete if you ever
get into a physical altercation you
either need to be complete you need to
completely avoid it and de-escalate or
be as swift and as violent as possible
there should be no in between economic
sanctions without swift military action
is foolish because just as we've seen
with the drug war they're going to find
an ally somewhere and like the point
like the point you made about germany
and russia you go from world war ii to
allies again sorry in world war one to
allies again in world war ii until
germany decided they were gonna say uh
no just kidding i had my fingers crossed
so
that's what's happening with china and
russia they're not natural allies no but
you're seeing what's happening with the
embargo on wheat being removed you're
seeing what's happening with the
hundreds of billions of dollars in
increases in in in trade you're seeing
what's happening with china now
supporting russia or at least condemning
the united states diplomatically not
calling it an invasion well if it was a
bar fight this is kind of like him
intervening and threatening to pay
putin's bar tap yes
no what he's doing is he's saying here
are sanctions they'll take a month to
take effect and really hit them and and
ducey asked this question to jen sackey
well it's good when you're in another
country right yeah i think do you think
that the ukrainians have a month
because i think they're dying right now
yeah maybe if we just stop buying their
oil today yeah make a difference for
christmas supplies have been shut off
the klitschko's just made welterweight
but when he brought up them burning uh
what's her face miles oh yes burn baby
no no no she it's worse than that nancy
pelosi i don't know if we can bring that
back up but that is a clip when he said
people who have lung damage she's
breathing in toxic fumes and burn pits
she trips over the desk trying to clap
and went
like she like if she were a superhero
she would just be the fly but this is
her only power
i am i am the cricket
tell me she didn't look like christmas
vacation ladies she did tell me
what was she thinking this is what
happens when you have people who fear no
accountability you know why look that
was absolutely insane okay what do you
think would happen if mike pence if
during a speech donald trump said
something like uh i don't know um you
know and uh the china varys they don't
like the chinese which he never said and
mike pence went
i love him and started doing like a
justin bieber heart or some [ __ ] guess
what it would be everywhere they know
they're not even concerned
about anyone on cnn abc nbc cbs i'm sure
we can flip around to see their
reactions saying this is pretty rough
yeah no that's not healthy where
well i will say actually it's not i
think that uh cousin eddie had it
perfectly right this speech the [ __ ]
was full tons of yes they got it all out
don't worry toxic smoke okay here we go
burn pitch
yeah
you've been there
what is she doing is she trying to throw
her voice
she heard clapping and she wasn't paying
attention so she stood up giddy and
smiling yeah for people's death not to
mention when he mentions he mentioned
cancer she started twerking yeah
that's weird because she can't do with
that no she can't it just re it sounds
like one of those noise clackers that
you get at steven you get it check your
tv when you're like you're 90
tomorrow she's on a commercial with
sally field i have osteoporosis
horrific twerking accident
right now there's homeless people
crabbing on my driveway i'm watching
through my ring doorbell please please
look at the bottom of this tapping oil
ah they just moved it tapping oil
supplies to kind of blunt the price
increase three days
yeah people from around the world have
released 60 million barrels of oil
three days of supply in the united
states three days of supply and demand
what are we doing on day four joe look
here's also something we need to talk
about look
it's very easy to solve the not to solve
but to mitigate the damage being done to
the american people now what did he say
we're gonna we're gonna force companies
to pay 15 an hour by the way the same
companies that they forced to close that
worked like a charm didn't it just look
at the economic results of red states
and blue states for example compare new
york to texas or florida you can debate
about the spread of the virus even
though it looks like red states did
relatively
better than blue states so you can say
okay maybe it's a wash there can be no
debate at all
none just to be clear none there's no
both sides of the issue as far as the
economic the disastrous economic
ramifications that happen with shutting
down businesses his remedy now is to
what force businesses to pay more okay
there are things that we can do right
now to solve this issue
as it relates to the average american
which he doesn't want to discuss by the
way use the hat use the hashtag biden
fact check that's the promo code 20 off
at lateralcredit.comclub
we're doing this stream live tonight
live fact checking a lot that goes into
producing it we make no money on youtube
here's what we can do
um
open up our own oil reserves now not
only does that help the united states
right open up not only our own oil
reserves but open up for as opposed to
shutting down the keystone products open
up our own natural gas oil reserves and
even clean coal technology not only does
it allow us to help our own citizens as
it deals with gas prices not only does
it allow us to be uh independent but
like we saw in 2016 under donald trump
for the first time in modern american
history allows us to be a next net
exporter of oil what does that mean
being a net exporter of oil means that
we can send out more oil than we bring
in hey who would we be sending that to
could that benefit people in the ukraine
could that benefit people in europe
particularly people who might be
dependent on oil supplies like the uh
like the nordstream pipeline right this
is the nordstrom 2 i'm assuming there's
a one
i have no idea
yeah by the way i have no idea but
uh what is it russia is responsible for
is it
10 is it 1
10 of the oil uh world's oil supply but
they're one of the single biggest
producers of oil uh for all of europe i
can find this any second uh you guys can
bring it up i don't exactly know what
the number is but the point is
we're now at a hundred dollars uh a
barrel for oil per day yeah and they're
talking about three-day supply of oil
and we were already we were already at a
high gas price anyway we were already at
a high gas oil was going up this wasn't
just a russia thing we when when the
united states focuses on its own
interests
it can benefit the rest of the world and
you know what it's a a perfect analogy
people say you need to put on your own
oxygen mask before you help the person
next to you right in the plane that's
you as a passenger okay
there is no more clear-cut example of
the pilot than the united states so if
you're a passenger you need to put on
your own oxygen mask first so you help
the person next to you the pilot
certainly should put his own oxygen mask
on first how do you know that we're the
pilot well we're the most powerful
country in the world not only the free
world we were paying all of nato more
than the rest of the countries combined
four years how do you know that the
united states is the pilot because when
[ __ ] goes wrong in the ukraine or across
europe they look to the united states
the pilot so guess what open our own
energy reserves here so we can help
ourselves and that allows us to help
nations overseas also when we're talking
about energy so we open up our own
resources and this is the key
you can't say wars for oil right no fx
rock against bush and now act like
that's not a huge component here with
russia in the uk ukraine of course it
has to do with energy something else
that we need to be doing is looking at
the most effective forms of energy
he won't talk about this because the
democratic party has maligned it for
years nuclear energy is not only
zero
carbon emissions just to be clear
entirely clean but there have been three
accidents and this is what the media
decided to of course sexify glorify
three mile island right chernobyl and
fukushima and in those cases
particularly fukushima almost all the
deaths came from the actual evacuation
plan yeah there is no form of energy
that has a lower amount of deaths per
kilowatt hour produced of energy than
nuclear energy and it's some that we can
use it is something that is effectively
renewable it is something that actually
creates very little waste and it is
something that is available to us right
now with no carbon emissions to see more
clear-cut examples look at the
difference between france and germany
look who cut their carbon emissions
france primarily nuclear energy versus
germany who went to renewables wind and
solar and not only did they increase
their carbon emissions they would have
brown outs they would have to sell
energy at a net negative cost so no one
is saying we wouldn't like to move to
all electric everything but right now it
needs to be powered by something and
right now we're powered by oil that
comes from places overseas as you have
seen by the way up until last week
well this week former vice president joe
biden supported signed off on the key
sign off of the nordstream pipeline
going through russia when one of the
first actions he had taken as president
we're shutting down the keystone
pipeline
here in north america so up until last
week he supported us being dependent on
foreign oil so if we want to go electric
in the future and you believe that it
runs on sunshine and farts accept
reality now it requires energy well
where does that come from do you want it
coming from the united states
or do you want it coming from russia do
you want to come from saudi arabia then
do you want it coming from zero carbon
emission nuclear energy that we can use
here in a safe reliable manner
or do you want nothing
because that's what you'll get with wind
and solar when you're dealing with that
kind of infrastructure just look at
solyndra look at these companies the
government has tried to shove down your
throat there are things we can do right
now
to make us less dependent on the rest of
the world and tyrants as former vice
president joe biden put it like vladimir
putin right now but he doesn't want to
do that up until last week he supported
buying more oil from putin absolutely
and you know how they know that nuclear
is totally safe they put it in things
that are getting shot at
the entire poi put it on a sub put it on
a carrier those things are targets if it
was so dangerous it's your noble like
one guy's arrogance anyway well it was
the russian it was the russian system
but it was like wasn't it just like one
who died oversight yeah like horrible
oversight to be terrible yeah which
basically started with you know they
didn't want measuring contest yeah the
domino effect lots of vodka yeah
lots of vodka and then people had three
testicles we don't know why well i don't
know if they necessarily had three
testicles some of them were starting off
with two and a half actually the button
to shut it down was at the other end of
putin's table and so it took a while to
get he's like oh why did they have 250
yard table i can't reach easy button
they were in a meeting and they were
like the buttons at the end nobody go
get it can you slide button like heinz
ketchup in jim carrey commercial from
80s
this is actually a fact uh before
chernobyl they had regular sized tables
oh my gosh
he just walked in he's like what
happened to my bangwood
right after the meltdown just there's no
long tables really
russian response from the uh governor of
iowa all right do you want to hear
anything republican response you just
said russian response you still have a
[ __ ] oh she's wearing red yeah she's it
looked like i'll drink fine i think i
saw her in the ivan drago montage
hammering families a violent crime wave
was crashing our cities and the soviet
army was trying to redraw the world map
even before taking the oath of office
the president told us that he wanted to
quote
make america respected around the world
again and to unite us here at home as a
weakling he's failed on both fronts
the disastrous afghanistan withdrawal
did more than cost america withdrawal
it betrayed our allies and emboldened
our enemies
north korea is testing missiles again
recently warned our olympic athletes not
to speak out against china and now
russia that being said it would be i
would be willing to have been wrong all
this time military interviews george
floyd is actually a deity and he just
sends locusts onto like nancy pelosi's
face
now all americans because they passed
and solidarity
of ukraine for sure
oh yeah i mean i would just a good
country crippling backhand i would kill
every person in this room because that
would allow me to see that we shouldn't
ignore what happened
to putin's
because he's a killjoy
russian pipeline prophet yeah bring you
back to life i'm not sure that's one of
those
fentanyl he might have used it already
if it were to he'll just go
he hasn't resurrected yet eight ball
it's like the smelling salts of cut
foods heal thyself position
all right stay out of this one
by the way this is one thing when people
ask why don't i more regularly support
republicans uh it's because it's pretty
tough to get behind this i know it's
it's a little lackluster here's the
thing you watched us fact check this in
real time and we'll do more fact
checking this obviously had to be
written beforehand it's almost like when
they do rap battles and like oh i have
this cipher you're like you just wrapped
you just rapped about a place where i've
never lived and never even been and my
mother's name is not ethel you're like
well that it was prepared beforehand
this is prepared beforehand and they try
to make minor changes this isn't real
it's why i do change my mind it's why we
do things like man in the street where
it's unedited and you just discuss with
people this isn't real it's not designed
to reach the american people this speech
right now is designed to reach the
republican donors we'll say well i
really like that kim reynolds because
you know he seems to be a good governor
plus she has breasts so we really need
to put her up on the ticket
yeah she's definitely the wild and out
of politics yes
just nick cannon winning everything
listen you have joe biden you couldn't
have put like a young like well-spoken
person in there like to be the
juxtaposition he had to match it crying
out loud you could have put bobby jindal
on i'd feel like i'm on mali
do any of them have their own teeth
anybody in politics from across that
checkpoint i'm not entirely sure about
the pain those are inflation on my
neighbor's faces
i don't know what you're talking about
but i like that sentence
it's all big fixodent at it again
high-class problems
i was pulling teeth out of my neighbor's
faces i saw mom's let's get the most
mouthy sounding
speaking of corn that's working overseas
for more of that as well to take home
she said decided tonight to go with
handmaid's tale sheep and now president
biden's hand made her hand maidens did
anyone know what the ukrainian flag
looked like five days ago probably not i
actually knew because i knew a girl in
high school who gave me uh uh he lent me
chrono trigger for my super nintendo and
i never gave it back sorry cecilia and
then um he had the ukrainian frag when
we did the cultural uh we did the
cultural fair ah yeah at least they
didn't end with hpv no you don't have to
check groceries not as far as not that
much
sorry cecilia it was a great rpg
chrono trigger is rare now it goes for
400 on ebay remember her lower back and
going what flag is that what but i guess
you have the last laughs
and i can tell you what's not on that
list tell us they won't tell you that
spending trillions more and bankrupting
their children is the answer to their
problems
they won't tell you that we should be
paying people i thought it was a fashion
thing i thought red was in
and they certainly won't be telling you
that we should give billions in tax
giveaways to millionaires and
billionaires all right okay let's do
this let's give our wrap up and then
we'll go to take some chat on mug club
because i you know what i'd be more
interested to hear ben shapiro's
no no we're not on mug club right now oh
what did you say nothing bad
all right what do you think there gerald
your wrap up it'll be more interesting
than governor kim reynolds yes so i i
think he did all the things we thought
he would do right he didn't speculate
his parents blame donald trump for the
nato thing so i was a little surprised
by that i thought he was going to at
least hint at that like the former
administration that tells me that
they had a focus group and they realized
it was an impossible set exactly like
they're like ah you can't do that i was
uh i was a little surprised that he
stumbled as much as he did like i
thought he would actually be able to
string a few more sentences together we
were drinking you kept hitting the damn
button tim
you're a little bit too on top of that
um and so he he stumbled through this
and i'm not surprised at all this is
something that i thought obviously would
happen
that the water would be carried by every
analyst on cnn no problem of course he's
powerful he's strong robert reich you
absolute [ __ ] measured powerful
response that did nothing to keep putin
from invading ukraine and killing its
citizens as you wrote that right that's
powerful to you
i think powerful means somebody stays
out of their neighboring country you
know kamala the small country next to
the big country in the big country and
invaded the small country that place
that's power right and he didn't address
that and then he blamed the economy on
all kinds of things but here's what you
needed to hear the government knows best
we're going to take your money and spend
it on everybody else by the way while
completely uh
refusing to acknowledge that the
government knows best policies which led
us here played any hand in what where we
are right now government knows best you
mean government knows best like shut
down businesses government knows best
like hand out checks indefinitely
government knows best like shut down
schools and go to zoom calls and by the
way the only reason they ever opened up
was because of the gnashing of teeth and
whaling from conservative moms who by
the way had a huge wins in in virginia
and almost in new jersey so the same
turnover that happened that you thought
now you're trying to take as a win and
saying by the way government knows best
government absolutely i don't think
there's ever been a more clear-cut
example created the mess that we're in
yeah and now he's trying to say but
don't worry government can fix it get
you out yeah just give us more money
give us more power do what we ask and we
will get you out do what we don't ask
well that's true what come on ask yeah
yeah yeah no it's a suggestion right
yeah and rape is just you know it's just
a suggestion it's just we didn't even
say suggestion i mean it's forward
yes
i'd say bold assertive yeah dominant how
do you trust a guy like that though he's
he's proven that he can rapist in one
year the president not the right i mean
it's close he's he smells people and
touches them in weird ways but by people
even children yes
how do you trust a guy then by rape year
has done nothing good
in one year he has shown you every
single measure nobody trusts this guy
and he's like just give me more power
give me more money
that's all i need yeah i'll fix it this
year right we're going to cut a trillion
dollars out of the debt really yeah how
are you going to do that you know what
our body we're going to we're going to
end all the burn pits and then was like
yes yes bird yes burn baby burn this is
a good time to release my song it's a
burn pit
from burnt
yes burn talking about my little burn
pit i just don't know where this came
from did she go to clap and she was like
i don't have fingers that move right now
i think she just wanted to feel she just
got so confused yeah yeah she was high
as hell she was really drunk i think she
was literally drunk hiding on her lips
like we're on benzos yeah she she
tracked or beamed one too many paddling
souls just chewing on her coke mouth
pricing
just right behind her there's a jim
henson poddling muppet who just looks
all dehydrated
how much adderall can i mix with vodka
[Music]
that diabetes boy looks nice and tasty
he that threatened
he promised to cure cancer well no he he
said yeah i don't think much more needs
to be said than that i mean it's really
it was lie after lie yeah and then he
promised to cure cancer that's where i
can't say that's a lie that's just a
bold statement hold on dave one of your
favorite things he said the va was going
to be efficient and make payments and
make and take care of that woman's
husband and the families the same way
they did with the vietnam veterans
across the country have died and left
their families with absolutely nothing i
know exactly what that feels like yeah
he's going to be right on top of it just
like he has been since the war in
vietnam since desert storm since the
since we've been in afghanistan since
well how many countries did he flub
tonight alone i think iran was one of
them what was the iran thing well one he
made up he said he mentioned ukrainians
he said iranian radio you think he said
uranium
yeah
uraniums what
he
it was just
it was just statement after statement of
just lies and nonsense more division and
i'll be honest um i'm surprised he
didn't stumble as much really yeah
exactly more i thought more wow so they
really gave him a good amount of b12 can
i and
real stuff maybe the cure you're saying
you don't think he'll cure cancer
oh no i obviously think he will can we
take a poll can we put a poll up on
twitter how many of you uh you know
considering how brave and powerful
they're claiming the speech to be how
many of you out there believe that
former vice president joe biden will end
cancer as we know it i don't want to
have
cancer
by the way you know what you do when
you're confident on something by the end
of the claim to end cancer by the end of
this decade we will put a man on the
moon and return him safely to earth
that's what you say you don't say we
need to get rid of cancer and be tougher
we're going to do a better job like he
didn't say here's a deadline go do it
right he didn't marshal the resources of
the united states and give us a goal and
say let's go achieve well it's like a
bad psychic right it's like a bad palm
reading if at any point in human history
cancer is cured it was still it was
former vice president joe biden yeah oh
yeah oh my gosh we knew it what we had
an oracle amongst us 40 years ago we had
no idea it was a long game we need to
consult the biden lineage
please raise up like dune
i just like that he yelled at the end of
the speech like bill pullman and evan's
dad yeah exactly yeah let's go or
attempt to i should say yeah he sounded
more like bill pullman and casper yeah
he started
so
um i'll tell you what i uh no i
appreciate that too because i was very
clear i always say folks listen yeah hey
come on cancer cures coming yeah cancer
cure you can't cure it
and the only tool you have against covid
is one that developed under donald trump
and you said you wouldn't take i killed
more people with coven than donald trump
i'm better now i'm gonna
do it with cancer oh please don't
go get him
go
go get him
killer t cells yeah he's like the coach
involved giving you chemo in advance
yeah
he's jogging out of the huddle okay or
the locker room let's go get him and
nobody's following him we call it our
new advanced chemo plan everyone next
speech comes in looking like justice
breyer yeah
that's great because when you get it you
won't lose as much hair hold on hold on
just have anything left yeah just some
sprite oh my what i didn't even ah it's
like crisco tan and a gay sketch i'm
like was that mango was that mango was
that justice mango he was laying it on
pretty thick
oh yeah he likes it late on things yes
i mean look come on
i couldn't help once you you just you
know you're just low hanging i do
respect his commitment is he out of the
closet oh is briar openly gay
or is he is he like a selter who's still
claiming he's straight under that robe
not a thing not a thing he just turned
around and mooned he just moon pelosi
look at this
oh my gosh gosh they love me
they really love he's talking about pete
butt gig he it's me he really me
um all right i will say that amber and
trans america yes
transparent
uh um i will say this we're gonna go
take your chat here in my club and hear
what you guys think uh and again the
promo code is biden fact check
you get twenty dollars off mug club
letters calm slash mug club you can go
to livestream.com slash tour i i it's
about what i expected i was shocked that
he spent
little to no time on the supreme court
nominee he went right he spent very
little time
on the economy right yeah
if that and uh he also it was very clear
especially when you hear when you
compare it to the rhetoric that we have
heard from saki and from former vice
president joe biden
about putin and donald trump emboldening
russia of course if they meant it they
would say it right now when all eyes and
by all eyes i mean however many
americans decided to accidentally
stumble across this channel um or any
channel right now because they broadcast
it on every single channel like the
indian head in the 1950s and that would
have been more entertaining if biden
just we just tuned in and elizabeth
warren was going
so i will say uh it was very interesting
you know you've heard me say this it's
like you see this a lot where people
make claims yeah and then they're in a
deposition or they're under oath right
they're under the the penalty of perjury
and they don't make those same claims
right now when there were more severe
consequences biden realized
i'm not gonna be able to sell the
american public on this idea that donald
trump uh emboldened and created the
problem with putin i'm not going to be
able to sell the american people on the
idea that donald trump weakened our
position with china so that's a very
stark contrast i also think the reason
why
uh is not only because it's a tough sell
to the american people but they know
what they're into what they're in for
with midterms and the red waves big time
and so that's why he tried to play up
the whole bipartisan look how many
bipartisan bills i've passed he's trying
to sort of ingratiate himself with
republicans because he knows that
democrats they're in for a massacre and
he's hoping to at least lessen uh
the portions of that massacre that are
seen to be on his hands so i did see a
start con to me it was surprising to see
that stark of a contrast
from everything he's been saying when
he's dictating the questions when he's
out there and these are press
conferences that nobody really watches
right and then the media clips and gives
highlights but when he knows this is
sort of like our show right we do this
live this is done without a net they
don't they don't do that a whole lot on
youtube especially now with the
community guidelines and the advertiser
friendly guidelines and sorry the
borderline content what's known as the
crowder rule apologize for that we do
this live and so what we say is of
consequence and we try to make sure that
we say what we mean and that it's
accurate and that's why we make all
references available at
lidearthcrowder.com by the way best
thing you can do if you're watching this
uh is smash the like button if you're
watching live and if you're watching the
archive just leave a comment with your
thoughts and here's why it's important
too for you to leave comments
and i don't this is the biggest
conservative
channel that's ever existed on youtube
okay
bar none and i'm incredibly grateful
that you guys have come in so this is
the place you will have more people
right now more of you will comment below
this video giving feedback with your
actual thoughts on this address
than on any other mainstream website
comment section it's it's it's something
that we are able to generate that is
undeniable where people can read your
organic it's the same reason they got
rid of the dislike button
yeah but although we can see behind the
scenes with our tools and by the way
still not going well for the white house
but uh i really would love to see what
you guys thought about this to me it was
shocking just because i thought
i i guess i i guess it's not that
shocking when someone is under the
limelight they're
let's think about it at press conference
i don't know what the average ratings
would be for a press conference when
sack is there you're talking maybe in
the hundreds of thousands right if
you're lucky maybe a couple million i
don't know how many millions of people
are watching tonight but he's going okay
the stakes are high i can't just use the
same old tired shitty arguments well the
world was watching hoping for a strong
response to putin right i didn't get it
yeah i mean there have there's so much
on the table right now i would assume
there had to be a large viewership i
would assume it has to be a russian
oligarch table yes well it's it's always
stable to have it's in gulag it's got
you see the table it's like this looks
like the ghost of christmas presents
wow come in and know me better man yes
all right i have grapes let's go and
take your chats here uh on mukklam and
of course thank you if you're watching
on rumble the more of you can switch
from youtube to rumble the free show is
always available on rumble we'll be back
on thursday 10 a.m 10 a.m eastern right
now we're gonna go and take your chats
your feedback and uh
let dave landau say whatever it is that
he wants to say oh uh of course on the
mug what just say
piss off youtube
you